okay
so
uh
i just analyzed my first three rounds
and now we're getting to the final round
the final round was a money round this
is just a four round tournament
and
[Music]
i played the top seed
let me figure out how to spell his name
romaine edouard
there we go
oh there's an accent over the e
yeah there's a spelling of romaine with
an e at the end but that's like the
leafy greens
pretty sure i played this guy
i'm so bad with like recognizing faces
it's one of those things like when i
play chess i don't really look at my
opponent
anyway uh yeah strong player
maybe we can find his feed a page
eat a rating of
yeah almost 2 600
and the reason why
romaine is in st louis as he's from
france
is
if you go to
the st louis chess club youtube channel
or if you physically go to the saint
louis chess club
there's weekly lectures that the grand
master in residence teaches
and he's been teaching them for
the last few weeks yeah so he has some
lectures
uh they're completely free on youtube
and like
very thorough like a lot of them are
hour long so
i used to do some of these back uh like
four years ago five years ago now
oh har krishnan says st louis chess club
is how i found eric
yeah if you sort by most popular i have
a few like kind of popular lectures
there's also a playlist
i don't know how i'd find it
probably by clicking on playlists
but uh this is the beginning of my
youtube chess journey before i make
content on my own channel so um i didn't
really have time to prepare specifically
but i will say before the tournament
began
around maybe 5
30
the tournament started at six
around 5 30 i
like really quickly
booted up my laptop and just like did
some general preparation for
for this guy and var
and uh kevlar veli just to have a sense
of what to do like if i played them
so i did look up um edward's
chess.com account before the tournament
and i knew to expect
uh this position after knight of three
and on chess.com he only had one game
in the move that uh i ended up playing
which is a6
i think in that game he played bishop g5
but it's some like random blitz game on
chess.com
uh in this game he played e3
which is
very solid approach
um
i've played a lot of different moves
even in this position but the point of
a6 is to
stay flexible and create a scenario
where
i can later take play b5 c5 bishop b7
and be happy
so
e3 is an attempt just to ensure this
pawn's defended and i didn't want to
take right away because then the bishop
just developed in one move
usually the strategy here
for black is to wait
until this bishop develops
before i take the bishop d3 were played
then i would take
mean time and
black's already doing quite well here
um what happened the game he played b3
and now
if i take it's likely the pawn will take
back
so i kind of gave up on the idea of
taking and just completed development
and then yeah we both played like very
natural developing moves
the move order might be a little bit
mixed up here but yeah we got to to this
position
and we're both fully developed
this is a very typical queen's gambit
declined type position
sometimes the bishop is here here rather
than on b2
but uh very solid setup for both sides
uh he took here look back with pawn
and we continue improving our pieces
i realized here that there's no need for
my bishop to be on e7 that's better on
d6
and it's actually useful that i played
a6 because now there's no knight b5
they played 92 rook e8 knight g3
and there's already some like annoying
ideas knight f5 spy play g6
and uh
there's times where g6 is weakening to
the dark squares
but white star bishop is so shut out in
this position that uh i'm okay playing
this
dark square bishop is a bit more
centralized
so a3 27 hitting the pawn
and this was rapid so we were playing
like at a pretty quick case here
4 94
and then he played the move which like
didn't cross my mind but it's
interesting is to play a4
and uh
essentially here he's saying oh no my
pawn
he didn't actually say that in the game
if i take then there's rook c7 and this
is
probably a very good trade for white my
bishop is hit
and the rook's annoying the e5 might be
coming
so i can't really take on b4
i over defended the pawn to threaten to
take on b4
but then after b5 a5
white now has this like kind of
positional bind on the queen side this
pawn is kind of backwards
where if i've removed it takes and
then these pawns could be weak
so
game continued there should be one
it was a very tense position
like we've only traded one pawn thus far
and uh we're both kind of just holding
our ground
and even though this is a backwards pawn
it's not like super weak just yet
i decided to try and make gains on the
king side
like h5
from idea h4
and now he took
not even giving the chance to play h4
x
and knight d2
and i was feeling good here i have a
well defended pawn in e4
and i have nice uh nice bishop diagonal
this bishop is a bit restricted by the e
pawn this bishop's restricted by the
d-pawn
and i thought there'd be a lot of like
attacking ideas
just with these these arrows
um but then during the game it wasn't so
simple
i played knight f6
uh with a sneaky threat which of course
he saw i'm threatening a greek gift
if white's not careful and plays
something like this i can take take here
and i assume this would be really good
for black
check
engine
oh
oh king h3 actually
yeah maybe it's not good for black king
h3 and i don't have this bishop move
okay i'm not sure like if this were
played in the game i'm not sure if i
would actually go ahead and take i would
think about it though
but uh
the practical approach here for white is
h3 just
don't even give me the option of bishop
h2
and then i play the move
which
i think in hindsight i kind of regretted
but in the moment i thought it was a
useful way to continue
[Music]
uh my ideas in the position
i played pawn c6
uh the reason for playing this
it was basically to put the bishop on b8
and then try and create the checkmating
battery
in the game there were some issues that
after white takes
i took with bishop
there is a very timely move from white
his pawn or not not yet pawn but first
knight c4
i played bishop b8
and now a very timely move
um in this position i i quietly said to
myself
oh no my pawn
um but this is a trap if white takes the
pawn
[Music]
another quiz for twitch chat
black to move and
punish white for being greedy
uh good job to everyone saying queen c7
and the one person who said queen c2 but
men queen c7
yeah this threatens mate and friends and
knight so
it's a nice thing about having the
bishop
is kind of sniping from base
um so the pawn is defended by tactics
but in this position
uh my opponent played pawn d5
and this was a really spicy move
because it looks like it's just a free
pawn like it's attacked by two minor
pieces only defended by the queen
but the point is it unleashes
the beast of a bishop on b2
and here i took some time because i was
a little bit flabbergasted
and realized that i have to be really
careful
uh because if i take with bishop
then there's bishop takes f6 and queen
takes i lose a piece
in the game i took with the knight
but hero white just sees his initiative
starting with queen d4
running two different mates
i played pawn f6
and then knight takes b6
wait a minute no that knight takes piece
wasn't played f3 was played
we actually we analyzed a little bit
after the game and we were analyzing
like just with uh lee leachate's engine
or my phone
uh it turns out knight takes b6 is a top
engine move
and white can get away with it in this
position
by notation here
um
and the difference
is that after
queen c7 i would have played this like
thinking
aha i'm
winning the night
uh this is white to move
and destroy black's hopes and dreams
white has a really kind of unexpected
move here
good job to steven willie
being tactically sharp yeah queen digs
d5
[Music]
the check is is stronger than the may
threat or forcing
and the problem here if i take the queen
i lose my queen i lose a bishop i'm down
a bishop wait no
i'm down
i'm down material here because i i have
rook for
knight and bishop but i'm i'm about to
lose more material i have six is coming
pretty much no matter what
so
we both missed that like he didn't play
knight b6 in the game but he played a
really interesting move
pawn f3
uh which i should make them
and
[Music]
yeah here my time was getting really low
because it was such a crazy position
and i'm temporarily up a pawn
but there were just so many things to
try and calculate here
and it was difficult
to like go through all the candidate
moves and try and avoid blundering
uh what i ended up doing was taking the
pawn
i think the engine suggests that i
should play queen c7 here
revoke f4 and then try and like close
things down maybe like rook cd8
this is a better way of playing for
black
but
yeah in the game i took
trying to open up lines against e3
the problem is after rook takes
there's the line against f6
which is attacked by so many things
and i play queen c5 here
and then in this moment like it was
actually crazy
after the game
uh
what am i saying
actually let me explain what happened
this moment this moment uh varus and the
kovian had like just finished his game
and like he walked by
i was like looking at our game and
eventually like we we continued but then
after the game verusion
just pointed out in this position
that white has like an absolutely
crushing move
um it was crazy crazy that var could
like just spot a move by casually
glancing at the game
but there's um
there's a really nice shot rook takes f6
here
which uh just completely destroys black
and
oh good job to joe suggesting rook f6
yeah the point is that uh
if i take with a queen then check
and like king here then takes and
bishop defends a rook
and if i take the rook then queen takes
f6 and i'm just getting crushed
um
and then like covers e3 so there's no
counter play
uh but my opponent fought for a bit here
and didn't take on f6 i was actually
expecting bishop takes g6
i was gonna play rookie seven and then
things still are like really messy
because there's still
some pressure with the g
file uh
but he took my queen
and then we go into an end game
and i was down like to below a minute he
was falling below like two or three
minutes
he took the pawn
i blitzed out bishop eight and he took
this pawn looks like all the things are
falling but i'm only down a pawn here
and then i won the pawn on e3
and then takes aches
aches so a lot of pawns coming off the
board
white has three
i have two
a wide open position my bishops are
wait a minute this didn't happen
this didn't happen i got confused when
he took on h5 first so i was not able to
win g2
and then
this happened so takes takes
and at this point i had like 30 seconds
left
and we had the two second increments so
like i had a little bit of time to
calculate
but it wasn't much
and i play the move that's based on
like a three or four move calculation
and the problem with the next move that
i played is i didn't calculate one more
move further
so just to explain quickly i was
calculating knight f4
temporarily stacking a bishop
and my point was that after bishop takes
a 92 check
king moves
knight takes c1 bishop takes c1
i would have bishop c7 hitting the
knight
and hitting the bishop
and i even looked at bishop b7 and um
brook to
[Music]
e8 in that line
and it looks like i'm winning a piece
and then what i missed was bishop d5
check
and then the bishop saved and white's
going to have two minor pieces for the
rook
and also have an extra pawn
uh so unfortunately i
i base my calculation off like a very
short think and
it's already difficult
to play for black but
um we went into this line
here here
you play king f1
and then here i realize there's there's
bishop d5 in the very end
i still took the
rook and he took
i still went for this line
um but after bishop d5
in g7
um i had another idea though like
because we kind of stumbled into this
position and after knight c4 i play rook
to
d8
trying to skewer the bishop to the d1
square
uh the problem is that white has a bunch
of ways to just deal with this um he
played knight e3 he also played bishop
f3
um now i was still trying to like make
things tricky
at this point i had maybe like around
five to ten seconds purely living on the
increment
he had less than a minute
i played bishop f4
making things extra spicy so now the
knight's pinned and my thread is to take
and
win the bishop
and this is where he unleashed just an
amazing sequence of moves
starting with knight f5
hitting my king and my bishop
but leaving this bishop hanging and
after king g6 this this and this are
hanging
all the minor pieces are hanging in this
position
or both sides
but then he plays knight e7
checking the king
saving the knight defending the bishop
and he's still attacking my bishop on f4
and i don't even have king of seven to
try and attack the knights i don't have
king five i have to play king g5
try and keep my bishop defended
and then he plays h4
and he's just trying to remove my king
from defending the bishop
i have king g4
and then he plays bishop f3
and i can't retreat i have to move up to
g3 to keep my bishop defended
and then knight f5
and all of a sudden i'm just getting
mated like i'm not even just losing the
bishop
i play king h2 only legal move
bishop takes bishop
engage one only legal move
and now white to move checkmate in one
on
g4 the late grab
such a cool mate too
because not even like g3 doesn't work
because it blocks a bishop like the pawn
has to move
two squares
i was happy to get opposition
but maybe white is the one with
opposition here
works in both directions
so anyway this was the conclusion of the
tournament
uh i finished with three out of four
but all the games were super fun
and i hope people enjoyed
seeing them
and seeing some of the analysis
um now the final story
is
there is a prize fund and i didn't think
i was gonna win money with three out of
four because there were a lot of people
who had two points going into the last
round who won so there ended up being a
lot of people finishing the three out of
four
and maybe one with three and a half and
bar also varacobian scored four out of
four so var and
i last round opponent edward mission and
a tie for first
uh however because my u.s rapid rating
is really really low compared to my
other ratings
uh real quick i'll show
my rapid rating or my u.s chess calls at
the quick rating
is 22.80
and there is an under 2400 prize
which i don't think the grandmaster is
qualified for
but i finished in like a
six or seven or eight way tie
for the under 2400 prize and i won 81
so it was a nice cash prize so anyway
that's
that's it but if you made it this far on
youtube
or on twitch
uh thanks for watching and
don't forget to subscribe
on both platforms and i'll see the
youtube people in the future